sixty-eight seconds of King logos so how
many shots of this minivan with the
towed u-haul trailer do you think we
need to sell the fact that these
characters are moving three I'm thinking
three four really Wow five what is this
the shiny five from New York it's my
sister gale
what special guest my nephew Zach that's
woman has either never seen an episode
of SNL before or the x-position fairy
sent her in to tell us what Zach and
Gail's names are movie actually spends
about a minute on this bedazzled Yankees
hat the sister made because the movie
has nothing it's just slowly stacking up
tropes in cliches family is moving
single mothers flying neighbor catered
rather live in Detroit bedazzled hat
making sister gets practically Sleepless
in Seattle if you read between ones
that's just bad packing right there no
one but yourself to blame really you
stay away from my daughter you stay away
from me we won't have a problem this is
five minutes after this kid started
moving it so either Jack Black is an
asshole or else Jack Black is an asshole
I'm gonna go get a head start decorating
my room not gonna fund my careless
decorating your room in the new house
you didn't want to move to is on your
bucket list you must have a really
bucket list dude putting up a wall
Donald Trump would like this kid well
mom I'm the new kid which presents its
own set of obstacles did he forget that
he's also pretty handsome and from New
York even though he hasn't even been in
the building yet the football team
already made a Jersey for him to be the
quarterback and the glee club is
formulating a plan to convince him to
join to help boost attendance that we
are so excited for Friday's fall dance
we can't stop twerking about it first
day of new school made even more awkward
by your mom being the new vice principal
is made even more awkward by said mom
telling a stupid ass joke even a mom
should know is stupid did I scare you no
really because you jumped like 10 feet
high um he didn't jump at all discount
Mila Kunis but nice try watch this
Wow Delaware is magically also the
abandoned forest carnival still has
working power hate the suburbs the
boredom the conformity the forced full
marvelous surprises and pretty girls
this movie is only 15 minutes in and
he's already got a hot neighbor who
wants to hang out with him leading him
into the woods to climb an abandoned
carousel my point is I moved six times
before I was 18 and I never once met a
cute girl next door let alone one that
had access to a secret theme park and
neither of these kids parents were
worried about them or looking for them
for the last three hours including the
mom who just moved here with her son and
didn't know he'd run off with the hot
neighbor girl and the obviously weird
and overprotective Jack Black we saw
earlier the least terrible time I've had
here well I'm sad what's so sweet
he's been you're literally 12 hours or
less the statement means nothing like a
lot of modern horror films this one
depends on the hero being a creepy
eavesdropper and a huge jumper of
conclusions so is it typical for the
person who called the police to
accompany them when they begin their
investigation I feel like that would be
against the rules she flew back to
London yesterday morning all right well
I checks out
how does that check out he didn't verify
anything yeah we haven't properly met
yeah Here I am standing in your house
okay this movie is now a rear window
ripoff wonderful whoa we're on that you
were no YouTube YouTube the causal van
solution to all of life's problems
don't scare a cuckoo clock that's weird
it's like the noise is coming from this
bookcase
it's just Matthew McConaughey's stuck
inside a tesseract I wouldn't worry
about it they failed to take the time at
any point in this movie to explain why
this happens it wouldn't take a lot of
effort they could say that RL has a
magic typewriter or he was cursed by a
gypsy or his books were manufactured by
the same company that made Jumanji but
instead they give us no explanation and
we're supposed to accept that his books
come to life for no reason let's just be
glad it's RL Stein that has this power
and not yell James yep I was right this
is book Jumanji just happen Zach you're
right that doesn't just happen but for
some reason it did just happen are these
the only two people awake in town how
did they follow the trail of a fucking
abominable snowman all this way from
their neighborhood and beat the fucking
cops to a vandalized storefront we
should call the cops have you met the
cops in this town
movie unexpectedly takes place in
Baltimore also dude you've been here 16
hours and your only contact with the
cops was when you overreacted and called
them on your neighbor with no proof of
wrongdoing
honestly the cops in this town should be
saying have you met this asshole Zach
come Percy Jackson and the abominable
candy bar monster
after saying opening the book was the
only way to reach wrap this thing Hannah
weights way too long to open the book
despite the urging of her new colleagues
thereby resulting in the book being
swatted away and some manufactured
tension forcing its way on-screen hooray
upon further review the Snowman entered
the net without being touched by a high
stick goal stands ok first of all that a
Zamboni would just be left on the nights
like this every surface 3/4 of the ice
ok
calling it a day right here now second
and third of all that this kid would
know how to drive a Zamboni and think
that's a viable escape method fourth of
all that idiot boy jumps off just in
time not to die from the snowman attack
unnecessary shushing come on hockey guys
can hold a two-storey abominable snowman
who knew I mean I've seen regular human
hockey players destroy glass like this
with a strong hit so I mean either this
wreck hockey rink glass is Tony Stark
designed or else this abominable snowman
is some weak sauce can you get called
for boarding on yourself cuz this thing
just it what are you doing Ron premature
celebration also see you should have run
you're doing a lot of standing around
when they should be looking for that
book
Jack Black ex machina which honestly I'm
amazed as a phrase I've never uttered
before now you're him are you you're are
a Stein if this kid knew enough about RL
Stein to know that he had gone missing
why wouldn't he know what he looked like
is this fictionalized version of RL
Stein a serial recluse Steve King wishes
he could write like me and I've sold way
more books in him but nobody ever talks
about that in Stephen King's defense
Stein has written like 300 more books
I'm not kidding
also this is the only true thing movie
has said about our all so far your RL
Stein that's you champ clearly just woke
up from a nap
RL leaves his front door wide open late
at night after fighting a monster and
insulting the neighbor kid makes sense
at least if you're the screenwriter
otherwise this door would be closed as
anyone was just eaten by Frosty the
Snowman which should be impossible by
the way so um no you're not
you were almost attacked by the
abominable snowman which is a furry
beast more akin to Sasquatch than a
common snowman like frosty but again
when I was younger no too early maybe
you should begin it I didn't give an old
beggar woman money in New Orleans so she
put a hex on me or something I created
my own friends monsters demons ghosts
we know he can write about anything and
have it come to life so why didn't he
write about some actual friends and a
girlfriend monsters demons and ghouls
are great for terrorizing the
neighborhood but they don't make great
companions oh no not him how did this
book end up unlocked anyway don't give
me that bit about the abominable snowman
rampaging around the Stein asshole just
said a book needed to be unlocked for
the villain to get out into the real
world so who won't want this new
terrible ventriloquist asshole the
director of the movie
let's get Jack Black basically uses the
same voice for slappy that he uses for
RL so if you look away while they're
talking to each other it's really hard
to keep track of who's saying what you
given me oh what's so what does lamps
roll credits please having limited use
of your appendages isn't an issue when
you can just I Dream of Jeannie yourself
to another part of the room and again
I'm not entirely sure slappy can do this
without an audible thunderstorm ear
about it's time I started pulling the
strings in this relationship if he's
going for a pun here I don't think
slappy knows what kind of puppet he is
unless he does know but just doesn't
want to say I think it's about time I
shove my hand up your ass for once he's
gone and he's taken off the books seems
to me that there is no size requirement
for things slappy can teleport if I had
that power I would have went a little
bigger he's taking all the books and my
surround sound system did I
Stein ripoff Stephen King constantly or
is it just this movie Oh is he reaching
the pedals it's locked from the outside
that's not how front doors work is that
a book the door that worked stupidly
movie turns into the darkest Travelocity
product placement ever there's a lot of
standing around going on for a group of
people that want to continue living
maybe they know this is a Nickelodeon
movie and no one can actually die Jack
Black in Gulliver's Travels whether or
not these evil gnomes thought ahead
enough to turn the oven on beforehand
why is it flaming inside that thing
that's a malfunctioning oven right there
and I wish the movie to stop and address
the issue before someone gets hurt
sorry folks I slowed down but I can't
reach the brake then how can you reach
the gas asshole come over to my house I
got on a laserdisc to the kids for which
this movie is made know what a laserdisc
is the officers you've been relieved of
your duties what the pros things do I
have to read all the Goosebumps books to
understand this movie cuz that noise
Jesus the scenery is like Back to the
Future 2 1985 meets gremlins meets Mad
Max just one one story to capture them
all what's that oh sorry my Tolkien
ripoff alarm was going off and I
couldn't hear you okay well then we got
to get you to a computer so you can
start writing alright there's it look
does it commute us alright here it gets
breaking convenient computer store is
very very convenient this gives children
a false idea of what high school dances
are actually like that needs to be about
three thousand percent more awkward
standing and I can't get any service
yeah no one can tonight either none of
the Verizon people can get service or
none of the AT&T people can get service
the evil plans only brought down one
tower the Sprint people wouldn't notice
because none of them can get service
anyway if all he does is slap the
annoying kid the invisible boy can't be
on that bad movie goes for the
inexplicable combo of Jurassic Park and
men in black unsurprisingly it doesn't
work let's just take one I'm sure
they'll understand Nickelodeon is
teaching me that looting is okay if I
had to choose between getting eaten by a
werewolf and wearing Axe body spray I
choose the werewolf every time wait just
a goddamn minute what grocery store puts
fresh lemons limes Raghu pasta sauce
bread and condiments all in the same
spot
there's even a frozen refrigerated
section up here on the right starting to
think you filmed this for the visuals in
action as opposed to any true grocery
authenticity this wolf is wearing gym
shorts and wrestling shoes and I don't
care what the fucking books say that's
damn ridiculous let's see him get
through that I wouldn't put too much
faith in that door it looks like a
pretty old door and the magic werewolf
is a magic werewolf so I think he's got
the upper hand
most convenient car ever I'm okay oh
good it's her because the story needed
more her your actual names champion well
I'm glad someone is making fun of this
so I don't have to do it my dad won a
bronze back in the 92 Olympics he won a
bronze in what vague achievements
untangling girl from a thing in a cute
romantic way cliche does moonlight
affect all the creatures like this or
just her feel like RL would be more wary
of letting Hannah go outside if we knew
the moon we're maker all blue and
sparkly it was awfully polite of the
zombies to wait until the moment where
it's revealed the Hannah is it real
before they attack also creepers come
out of the gray to attack our heroes and
suddenly I'm in a Resident Evil movie
yet again this is a decent sized town
are there really only two cops I love
her in such a way that she thinks she's
real can we explain any of this after my
dad died I should ever went out to
completely forgot about the dead dad so
if no one in this town knows that he's
actually are else dying and they're
constantly moving from place to place
and why the fuck is his typewriter
memorialized in the school I have a
deadline literally unbelievable okay I
school lets their students put on a
production of the shiny so this is what
a high school dance is like oh no no
it's not this is going to sound insane
but monsters have invaded Madison if I
can get just one insane person at this
high school dance to believe me
this just might work also with the town
basically destroyed you think news of
something would have reached these kids
already via panic parents or cops and
with the main characters not having a
cell phone service wouldn't all these
kids not have cell phone service too
when there'd be an element of
something's not right going on these are
all the exits I'm glad that zach had one
day of school here so he could
familiarize himself with all the exits
nope slappy who is supposed to resemble
Stein looks more like Rod Serling Man
Bites Dog he's when I was ten I didn't
brush my teeth for a whole year
Halston sage seems doomed to play the
hot girl that ends up liking the dorky
kid and every movie she's in the
spotlight kid at the school is super
into his job everyone in the high school
joined forces this movie is way more
Chuckie than I think it realizes this
giant seemingly unstoppable plant is
thwarted by some like kicking the moon
light shines on Hannah at some pretty
convenient times or inconvenient
depending on how you look at it slappy
is a dick to the school football field
also I don't understand this slappy sent
all the monsters into the school to find
and kill Stein but many were just
killing students now that Stein is
leaving like the monsters only wanted
Stein in the first place because they're
all following him now so why kill the
innocent kids earlier is it
mountain-climbing because they were
there look I'm not saying it's
impossible for a few high schoolers to
rig up something this advanced and
complicated in three minutes on the fly
but I am saying it's practically
impossible high-five oh yeah his fingers
are all smashed a broken which is
impacted by a high-five but not by
driving a goddamn bus for some reason
follow the scent leave me - Skyy okay if
stein was never here and it was a dummy
you driving the fake bus there's no
scent to follow also that bus should
have crashed miles ago but whatever also
whine while the monsters obey the tiny
wooden ventriloquist puppet all these
monster things are evil presumably so
why they all falling in line with this
assholes commands shouldn't one of these
eat slappy and take control also this
werewolf died and came back to life be a
swirly magic and is still wearing jean
shorts there are now a dozen Slappy's
you know it would help if the movie
explained any of these book monsters
abilities before making our heroes face
them know just in case you didn't get
that slappy was a representation of RL
himself here's this it's higher ground
thank God the blob that hate everything
surrounded them on all sides except the
route from here to the ferris wheel also
how will high ground help obi-wan slappy
operates wherever the he wants to go in
this entire movie Stein who is key to
the entire movie just decides kick and
write like me and wanders off to face
the blob but seriously everything this
movie tells me suggests it has to be
Stein that writes the book not the kid
so this is simple no one dies because of
this or this thankfully that crash they
shouldn't have survived and with their
ferris wheel car being inches from the
ground phew I mean right but for real
though how did they not get ejected from
the seats they weren't strapped into
while this thing aggressively rolled
down a hill if we open the book that
means also Zack was a dumbass and didn't
write except for Hannah at the end of
the book voting all this heartache
how many sweet 16s come on girl half I
guess - before you start to get
suspicious I've got you because that
will work yeah please not happy and
Stein's not fine
this dangerous a scaffolding painting
bull with definitely 100% not be going
on during the time hundreds of kids are
entering the school Oh
what did I have for you there it is you
a movie
my name is mr. RAL Stein and I will be
your new English teacher my net worth is
200 million dollars so you know I'm in
this for the learning so I guess this is
the same Hannah but it's from a
different book get on almost done first
off the invisible boy is invisible not a
ghost right how the hell is this guy
behind glass typing the second off
invisible boy is absolutely circling up
a sequel to this bowl Disney
Delaware hi I'm in Delaware
she'll be way it looks like a pink
nightmare
oh he's a Guinea Oh piece of candy Oh
pizza candy there you're free to go
you are now free to move about the
country